foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar tips tricks and optimization a
user's guide to bondrx and chromogenic
multiplexing and research research
applications I am Kaylee Bach of
labyrinths and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by labroots and
brought to you by Leica biosystems to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit likeabiosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Mark
Lawson certified histo technologist by
the American Society for clinical
pathology
field application Specialists too Life
Sciences like a biosystems Mark you may
now begin your presentation
hello hello thank you so much for that
introduction
um
um so my name is Mark Lawson uh thank
you for joining uh Us in this webinar um
I'm here to present tips tricks and
optimization it's going to be a user
guide to the bond RX and chromogenic
multiplexing in the research application
so
um my name is Mark Lawson I'm an
application set specialist on the life
sciences team at Leica biosystems
um I provide technical support for the
life sciences portfolio
um including but not limited to the bond
RX the bond rxm and a wide arrive a wide
array of reagents
so I've worked in the histology field
for about 15 years in both the clinical
and research spaces I started off as a
histo technologist and worked my way up
to management uh fairly quickly so with
this experience I've been able to
develop my skills in
immunohistochemistry and insight to
hybridization assay Development
Laboratory management and general
histology to a pretty high level
um so when I'm not thinking about which
primary antibody is best suited for a
particular application
um I like to spend my time with my
family and friends
um enjoy everything that the North Shore
of Massachusetts near my home
um has to offer and also uh play a
little golf
so again welcome welcome welcome
um so this presentation was
um developed for all levels of
practitioners but I do assume that you
have some familiarity with um
immunohistochemistry and multiplexing
Technologies
um at the end of this presentation uh
you guys should be able to recall two
types of assays that could be run on the
bond RX
describe two ways researchers can
optimize IHC and Multiplex staining and
identify one best practice solution for
running chromogenic multiplexing so that
is included in the optimization uh
category
yeah so let's just go over the basics of
immunohistochemistry just go way back to
the basics so again immunohistochemistry
has evolved to complement hematoxylin
and eosin and special stain technologies
that typically show tissue morphology
and structure
um while these two technologies are not
specific you know sometimes they can be
specific but mostly not
um IHC is directed to specific protein
marker or markers
um typically the chromogens that are
used
um there are two of them so dab which is
the brown and AP which is the red
dib is used for most applications uh it
provides a strong and permanent uh stain
you know with that covalent bond
um AP is is mostly used for skin
sections
um specifically in the clinical world
where dab may be masked by other Brown
pigments such as melanin
for double staining the tradition is to
use dab and AP on the same tissue
section and here you can see that that
construct of of the primary antibody
secondary antibody and polymer in this
case it's horseradish peroxidase with
the dab
making that brown precipitate
so what's next what type of Technologies
are going to be available to researchers
uh to look at these markers and RNA and
DNA so multiplexing allows multiple
markers to be stained within a single
tissue section
it uses combinations of different
markers and chromogens to build a more
complete image of the tissue structure
Multiplex methods can visualize multiple
Target antigens DNA or RNA within a
single tissue sample
um you can either do it sequentially or
simultaneous also known as parallel
where you would take um you know uh
maybe up to three different primary
antibodies cocktail them together
um and come in with the chromogens
now the workflow for specifically uh
sequential multiplexing allows for
multiple rounds of retrieval and or
reagent stripping
it can be used with it IHC and ish in
any order
and it can work with chromogenic and
fluorescent workflows so the basic idea
is you have a d-wax and retrieval
your primary marker is applied
your enzyme is applied so whether it be
alkaline phosphatase or horseradish
peroxidase
a chromogenic conversion of the
substrate happens
and then you add your counter stain but
you can do this doing using multiple
rounds so in a sequential Multiplex
you'll do this you know for instance for
a four Plex four times
now why are people multiplexing these
days
um so multiplexing provides new insights
into what's occurring on a cellular
level so you can really look at the
cellular interactions learn the
functional cell States
understand the direct relationship
between the DNA RNA and protein within
the cell so that translational happening
you can understand spatial arrangements
so are those macrophages close to that
cancer cell
you can understand interaction so is a
macrophage interaction interacting with
that cancer cell and you can really see
co-localization so really dive in to see
what kind of immune cells you're looking
at
so uh multiplexing really maximizes the
amount of data acquired from a single
tissue sample
um some popular multiplexer applications
that are used today include pin4 which
is ck5 p63 amicur p504s and that's in
prostate a dual Plex so Kappa Lambda and
lymphomas
um and for melanoma we have Melanie
tyrosinase hmb45 in chi-67
now you know historically IHC has been
performed as a manual process right
so this can cause a lot of variability
in your research project outcomes
um you really have
um you know various uh points that you
have to control while doing the assay so
independent Hands-On techniques so user
to use their variability
uh temperature variability so you have
to make sure that your microwave and
your pressure cooker are you know at the
correct temperature at all times
you have your time variability so you
know you'll see researchers running
around with uh timers on there on their
lab coats um it's a very time sensitive
assay
and it also takes time to prepare
reagents you know never mind that dab is
highly carcinogenous so if if you're uh
mixing dab it's it's probably not the
safest procedure to be uh doing
so automation can offer a built-in
consistency it can monitor the sample
condition and application
um so I just want to give you a little
bit of a glimpse of the bond RX so we'll
be talking about the bond RX in more
detail going forward
um so in 2011
um like a biosystems released the bond
RX
so the efficiency of fall automation is
matched to unlimited reagent selection
and freely customizable protocols so you
can use any reagent you'd like and
develop any type of re of protocol that
you've developed on the bench on the Bon
RX
so the bond three from like a biosystems
was very restrictive
um this new Bond RX offers unprecedented
Choice with researchers able to select
the ideal reagents dispense sequences
and incubation conditions for a study
now just last year in 2021 Leica
biosystems released the botrx software
version 7.0
this software allows you to conduct up
to a six Plex sequential staining with
IHC ish and IHC plus ish
you can run chromogenic and fluorescent
multiplexing in parallel so you'll have
one assay and that's chromogenic one
assay that's fluorescent you can run
them at this on the same time on the
bottom RX
uh you can do up to six instrument mixed
chromogens that can be applied to a
single slide so you can purchase a
chromogen from an outside company
um and the chromogene multiplexing
function functionality is supported by
some new reagents so in particular the
blue and green chromoses and also open
chromogen functionality which is uh
using a new detection system
so why is IHC done in research right so
historically Western blotting and mass
spectrotomy uh
Mass spectrometry sorry I can't uh
really talk today
um can give a researcher evidence that a
particular piece of tissue expresses a
particular protein
now IC can determine where in the tissue
that protein is found
um the protein can be visualized in this
cellular context
therefore I see is a tool that can be
used in a wide variety of research
settings and applications and these
might include oncology neurology
Immunology diabetes studies pre-clinical
drug development toxicology and pharmaco
pharmacokinetics
so getting back to Multiplex IHC
um so what are some issues and questions
that arise typically when you're
developing a multiplex IHC assay so
first off this is a very long assay in
terms of the time it takes to complete
um again reproducibility uh there's that
idea that you know uh it's very hard to
control each and every uh
part of the essay
um some might ask what reagents are
needed to perform a chromogenic
multiplex ihcsa
and also how do I optimize chromogenic
Multiplex uh a paddle you know uh how do
I know that my markers are hitting their
targets and these chromogens are you
know really highlighting the antigens of
the interest
so I want to give you some solutions for
these issues
um and answer some of these questions so
I want to introduce the bond RX the
automated research staining platform
that can automate your Multiplex IHC
assay uh really giving that high level
of reproducibility
I want to provide some useful Guidance
with tips and tricks to set up and run
chromogenic Multiplex IHC slides on the
botrx
I also want to provide sort of a
step-by-step guide at the slide setup
level on how to configure the Bon RX
version 7.0 software
and I want to provide a starting point
for chromogenic Multiplex IHC panel
optimization
so let's get let's dive right into it
let's Dive Right into uh our user guide
here
and again the purpose of this is is to
really show you some Multiplex IHC
images to provide some useful guidance
on how to set up and run chromogenic
Multiplex slides and also that
step-by-step guide on how to configure
the bond RX 7.0 software at the slide
setup level
and here's just a presentation roadmap
for you
all right so let's get started with uh
just some general information uh and
guidance all right
um so tips and tricks right so as a
general rule uh the chromogen should
always be applied in the following order
so the red chromogen dab blue and green
um the red chromogen is alkaline
phosphate phosphatase based so you want
that to go first because it could
interact with the hrp uh enzyme reaction
and therefore if you put the red for
instance in the second slot uh it would
be much dimmer than uh you would expect
so the selection of dehydration
procedure is very dependent on the most
susceptible chromogen so
um when you are dehydrating after the
slides come off the bond RX
you need to uh keep in mind that the red
and green chromogens can be taken
through standard dehydration procedures
using alcohols and xylenes but they
should not exceed 10 dips or 10 seconds
um so the chromogens will fade and
crystallize
um and every single one of these
chromogens have been optimized to use
the Leica biosystems CV Ultra melting
media
um the blue chromogen is not compatible
with alcohols and xylenes uh you must
air dry at room temperature or in a oven
at 37 or 60 degrees C
again you can use CV Ultra if you're not
using CV Ultra please use a aqueous
melted
um and again if the blue chromogen is
used utilized in a multiplex assay then
the stain slide must be air dried
the blue chromogen is photosensitive
um you cannot leave it in direct
sunlight or uncovered for a prolonged
period of time
so Bon RX software version 7-0 enables a
sequential staining of up to six
chromogens in one fully automated run
um you do not have to remove the slides
from the instrument to achieve this
um so any software version prior to
version 7.0 do require that the slides
be removed from the instrument after the
first two detection applications you're
going to re-label them with a newly
reprogrammed probation applicant
protocol
application protocol
and then you return it to the instrument
for scanning
um so it is possible to do multiplexing
with any version software prior to 7.0
um we do have a new red counter stain
which is optimized for use in
conjunction with blue chromogen
um if you prefer less intense color
contrast of hematoxylin or another
counter stain the incubation time can be
reduced to three minutes in order to
increase the contrast with the chromogen
or you can dilute the counter stain
um this is a great tip here if if the
red chromogen and green chromogen are
selected to visualize the target
antigens
um a third purple color which looks
fantastic will result from
co-localization of staining within the
same cellular compartment
all right and this this section is
really the uh my favorite section uh
first of all
um so I'm going to provide a
step-by-step guide on how to set uh
certain Multiplex assays up at the slide
setup screen and also tell you a little
bit about the slide
um and the chromogens and markers that
were used
so a little bit of a disclaimer the
information here is provided for
guidance only uh it does not infer the
optimum optimum usage of the materials
um the slide images are provided for
information only and were generated as
part of product development and have not
fully optimized or validated
um alternative episode retrieval steps
May yield better results and also
including blocking and stripping steps
May further optimize performance
all right so here's our first beautiful
image
um this is with a piece of tonsil tissue
using pdl1 cd68 cd8 and pan CK markers
so pdl1 exhibits in tonsil as a weak to
moderate punctuated membranous staining
of the germinal center macrophages and a
moderate to strong staining of the
majority of epithelial Crypt cells uh
cd68 exhibits in tonsil has a moderate
cytoplasmic staining of interfollicular
macrophages
um like a biosystems clones specifically
displays strong cytoplasmic staining of
germinal Center macrophages
um cd8 exhibits in tonsil is membranous
staining of the cytotoxic subpopulation
of T cells and pain CK exhibits in
tonsil as strong staining of epithelial
cells
uh so using this combination of immuno
oncology markers we can reveal details
on a tumor microenvironment
and uh can provide sensitive and
specific predictions
on clinical outcomes by assessing the
infiltration of immune cells macrophages
and T cells
um so pants CK exhibits in tonsil is
strong standing of epithel epithelial
cells again
um
so as you can see in the slide setup
screen this gives you a breakdown of
exactly how this beautiful image was
produced on the Leica Bond RX in version
7.0 software
so the first stain second stain third
stain and fourth stain
and if you have any questions on exactly
how to set these up on your instrument
please contact your local application
Specialist or reach out to your account
your sales uh counterpart
um and they can obviously help you do
this
uh here we have a colon
and we're using ck20 Desmond CD3 and
cdx2
um so notes on this so four uh this was
scanned on a a like a biosystem scanner
by the way
um so four like a biosystems chromogens
have been used on the borax Bond RX 7.0
to illustrate the multiplexing capacity
of the sustaining platform uh the
chromogens were used to detect four
primary antibodies in normal large bowel
as seen in the image Lim Legends over
here and on the left
um the two layers of smooth muscle
surrounding the bowel is easily
visualized with the Leica biosystems dab
chromogen
Desmond is expressed by the muscularis
externa in both the longitudinal and
circular muscle
uh dab chromogen detects the anti-desma
primary antibody which binds to the
tissue expressed Desmond generating the
characteristic brown staining associated
with the ab
within the inner mucosa layer the
muscularis mucosi is also visualized
with dab Desmond complex and the smooth
muscle cells among the epithelial cells
of the Lumen are also visible
Papyrus patch is present in the
muscularis mucosae detected using the TC
T Cell markers anti-cd-3 and visualize
what the Leica biosystems blue chromogen
the mucosal layer has been stained with
anti-cdx2 to show the epithelial
goblet cells in the colonic Villi
detector using Ligon biosystems green
chromogen and anti-ck-20 which is
expressed cytoplasmically in the surface
epithelial epithelial cells of the colon
and detected using Leica biosystems are
retina
so here is is also a beautiful image of
a lung so we're using ttf1 ck5 and naps
in a uh with our beautiful red counter
stain
um this is also scanned with a like a
biosystem scanner
um ck5 and ttf1 are markers used to
differentiate I don't know I don't know
carcinomas of the lung from squamous
cell carcinomas of the lung so generally
I don't know carcinomas Express ttf1 and
squamous cell carcinomas Express ck5
this image demonstrates a lung
adenocarcinoma using ck5 ttf1 and naps
in a generated using Multiplex
technology available on the bomb RX
ck5 is expressed by normal squamous
cells such as those lining the bronchus
and the bronchioles leading to the
alveolar sacs
anti-ck5 was used to detect the
cytoplasmic expression of the ck5
antigen resulting in the characteristic
brown chromogen staining evident in the
bronchiole
in long naps in a is produced by type 2
pneumocytes alveolar macrophages and
some respiratory epithelium within the
cell cytoplasm
ttf-1 is expressed by type 2 pneumocytes
and Clara cells within the cell nuclei
so markers can be visualized in
different cellular compartments with
ttf1 detected without like about systems
red and napsum a detected using like
like
a biosystems blue
and again this is another colon using a
four Plex so
um so some notes on this uh the
muscularis mucosis comprised on Desmond
expressing smooth muscle cells so
visualized with lbs green chromogen
actively reproducing lymphoid cells are
evident with the chi-67 biomarker and
dab chromogen surrounded by mature T
cells expressing CD3 and detected with
the lbs blue chromogen to form a pyre's
patch
epithelial goblet cells which form the
mucosal lining of the large bowel
Express tk20
has been visualized with the lbs propyl
chromogen
enterochromatin cells Express serotonin
these neuroendocrine cells are present
in small numbers in the laminopropria
but are clearly visualized using
anti-serotonin antibody and right
chromogen
the higher magnification dividing
epithelial cells forming the bowel Lumen
are detected by the nuclear Express
chi-67dab
migrating T cells are also easily
differentiated due to the royal blood
blue chromogene color contrasting with
the hematoxylin counter stain
additionally smooth muscle cells
supporting the Villi are detected by the
cytoplasmically expressed Desmond
visualized by the green chromogen
so again you can see how this was put
together at the slide setup level on the
Bon RX 7.0 software
so here's the first stain the second
stain
third stain fourth stain fifth stain
um here is a prostate also using the red
counter stain
um
this prostatic adenocarcinoma is
characterized by the loss of basal cell
antigens ck5 and P40 in the ductal
epithelial cells of the prostatic glands
so benign cells transform into malignant
cells which express Amica
this is evident using the three Plex
technology of the bond RX with lbs
chromogens
the non-malignant
and malignant ducts are clearly
differentiated by the strong cytoplasmic
expression of ck5 in the blue in
contrast with cytoplasmic expression of
amicur detracted with the red chromogen
at a higher magnification the nuclear
P40 expression can be seen surrounded by
the ck5 blue expression denoting benign
cells
and finally this is just an example of
how the red chromogen and the green
chromogen can show the co-localized
purple
so we have a piece of tonsil staining
with um bcl6 and chi-67 with the
hematoxyl encounter stain
um you can see the little cells uh with
the number one is the red chromogen
that's going to be bcl6
uh and number two which is the green
chromogen which is chi-67
um cells undergoing uh proliferation
um and again with the two markers you
get the co-localized purple and three
so here's some information about how to
order uh all of the reagents that you
saw in those setup screens so
um if you have any questions again reach
out to your local application
Specialists from the life sciences group
or you can also uh contact your
salesperson
all right moving on we're gonna talk
about some general chromogenic Multiplex
panel optimization tips and again this
is just to get you started I mean this
this this process can get somewhat
cumbersome uh it's a lot easier
chromogenically than it is using
fluorescent uh Technologies but here are
some tips that are going to help you
so first off for co-localized markers
um consider using chromogens that will
create a third color so again using that
red
and the green uh from Leica biosystems
you can produce that purple
um if you want to detect multiple
proteins that are highly and lowly
expressed in tissue uh consider using a
stronger colored chromogen first for the
lower express marker
followed by the weaker color for the
highly expressed marker
this may avoid overpowering the initial
stain of the low Express protein
um so this idea could also be applied if
you expect the quantity of one cell type
to exceed that of another
so some chromogens convert at different
rates so for instance you have your red
chromogen and what looks like your blue
chromogen here
so lots of precipitate equates to a
stronger signal and we all know that red
uh gives you the Lego bio substance
where it gives you a very strong color
so slow precipitating chromogens May
prevent this overwhelming signal of
other markers
um for spatially close targets
uh consider selecting chromogene colors
for these two markers first uh so run
these as dual stains prior to the
multiplex panel to select the best color
combination then address the optimal
order for the remaining marker colors
possible run these as dual stains prior
to the full Multiplex panel to select
the best color combination then address
the optimal order for the remaining
marker colors
um you also want to test the stability
stability of different chromogens
against subsequent experimental steps
and there are a number of ways to do
this
um I'm not really going to go into
detail here but you can ask your local
application Specialists and also there
are many resources
um on the internet
um so signals that remain strong use
those earlier in the assay and less
robust signals later in the experiment
um
so lighter chromogene colors may be
easier on the eyes to visualize so let's
just think of our Pathologists here or
you know uh principal investigators
um
especially if you have co-localizations
or
if you have multiple markers in close
proximity to each other
okay
um number seven dab can overstain and
occlude previously stained
um
sites so all although dab is is cobbling
you is the most commonly used chromogen
for a single stain immunohistochemistry
uh it's an example of a chromogen that
can occlude spatially so
um if you're using dab optimize the
sequence in which it's used to find a
suitable place within the multiplex
panel
foreign
so this is very important so consider
your choice of preferred counter stain
with the chromogene colors
um
half strength hematoxylin if you'd like
it lighter you can also use methyl green
or nuclear fast red
this is especially true if you're
conducting image analysis studies uh
teal or blue chromogens may be in the
indistinguishable from hematoxin counter
stain so you may want to try a methyl
green or nuclear fast right as I as I
mentioned earlier
um also consider the compatibility of
your chosen chromogens with your
required or preferred dehydration
methods so again in the tips and tricks
section of this webinar we went over
some
um some very hard guidelines that are
associated with like a biosystems
chromogens so please follow those and
consider them when you are dehydrating
um so you want to determine which
antigens are robust or susceptible to
degradation following multiple rounds of
antigen retrieval
and you want to consider detecting the
susceptible markers earlier in the assay
so there again there are multiple ways
of testing this out I'm not going to go
into detail now this is going to be a
starting point for you
um you do have
um many resources
um available to you on the internet as
well as uh I'm sure your colleagues have
some tips and tricks that they can tell
you
so in summary uh multiplexing provides a
multi-color multi multi-target slide
it's a permanent stain unlike some
fluorescent assays
it's resistance uh to photo bleaching
is another reason why people might
choose this assay over
um fluorescence
and it's great for bright fi bright
Fields image and Analysis so you can use
image analysis uh algorithms with some
of these assays
so like a biosystems does have a
publication repository so if you want to
read some peer-reviewed Publications
featuring the bond RX you can head to
this link here I'm sure in the methods
section you can find plenty of great
tips as well uh that may help you along
your journey we also have a new life
science portal home page that was uh
launched recently so definitely check
that out we have plenty of of great uh
resources available
um at this link
so that concludes my uh presentation
um
thank you very much for joining me I'm
happy to open up uh for any questions
that you may have
um so yeah please let me know uh if you
have some questions
thank you Mark for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so it looks like our speaker needed to
do a quick refresh so we'll give them
just a second to get reconnected back in
here
all right it looks like our speaker was
having a few technical difficulties
but he's still trying to get connected
here so we'll give him one more second
thank you for your patience
there we go glad you were able to get
that connected in here thanks Mark
sorry about that a little technical
difficulty that's okay we got you now
that's all that matters thanks so much
we've got some great questions coming in
here from the audience so we'll go ahead
and get started our first question asks
what makes the bond RX unique to the
research setting
yeah so that's a great question so like
a biosystems does have a clinical
platform called the bond three which is
very closed
um it's an FDA regulated box so
therefore you know you really have to
file some strict guidelines so the bond
RX allows you to open up
um the research platforms so you can
bring on any reagent that you'd like uh
pending it's not too acidic or basic and
also you can bring on a number of
different uh protocols as well
great thank you another question we have
here asks how many chromogenic
biomarkers can be stained on one side or
excuse me slide using the bond RX yeah
another great question so you can do up
to six uh different biomarkers with six
different chromogens
um like a biosystems does have four
chromogens so obviously dab
um red uh green and blue uh but you can
also bring on uh you know outside
chromogens that are horseradish uh
peroxidase based
great
next question here on average how long
does a multiplex assay take to stain on
the bond RX
ah another great question
um so that's highly dependent on the
number of the types of steps that you
have in your assay so typically a single
marker with chromogen takes about two
and a half hours to three hours
um so you can you know depending on how
many markers and corrosions you have can
take between three to up to 12 hours
great we've got a
oh that's about it yeah perfect okay
great thank you got some great questions
coming in from our audience this next
one asks do you recommend using controls
for single and or Multiplex stains
oh 100 so histology uh IHC without
controls is uh yeah it's something that
I I highly highly recommend
um always use a uh positive control and
negative control uh when you are are
optimizing uh single Plex uh
um markers with your chromogen I also
suggest using it with your with your um
with your Multiplex panel
um IGG controls so immunoglobulin G
controls uh will help you understand the
background that you're having with your
chromogens as well
um so I highly suggest using those
um yeah
great our next question here asks how
does the red counter stain perform with
image analysis software Halo Vizio Farm
etc for cell segmentation
ah this is uh
a little bit outside of my expertise so
I I do try to focus on the bond RX but
if I were to talk with some of my
colleagues
um over in the image analysis
um Team
um I I from my understanding
um it works well
um although you would probably have to
talk to an application specialist on
that team
um I do know that that those algorithms
uh prefer a deep dark purple
um although I'm yeah I would have to
defer to my image analysis team
great
next question here is there a way to
dilute the dab in the kits
um
not necessarily dilute the uh the
reagent I would suggest maybe
um trying to
um
lessen the time of the incubation time
possibly for the dab there are various
ways to reduce the signal as well such
as dilution of the primary antibody or
even dilution of your secondary antibody
although if you're using the post
Primary in our refined dab kit I don't
suggest diluting that so maybe working
with the incubation time of your dab and
also the dilution of your primary
antibody would be the best you know sort
of road to go down
um I don't suggest diluting dab
um from our kit from a ready to use kit
great thank you another question we have
here is version 7.0 of the software
available to those who purchase their
bond RX prior to 2021 or is it
additional charge for upgrades
so yeah
um I would defer to your sales associate
absolutely
um you know uh I there is a an uh
upgrade charge
um depending on what setup you have
um yeah the price could vary so
definitely talk with your sales
associate
um talk with your application
Specialists and they can bring you down
the correct Road
perfect yeah another great question we
have here when multiplexing using four
or five different chromogen combinations
do your primary antibodies have to be
made in different species this can be
challenging
yes excellent question
um
so you can use uh the same species so
this is a sequential staining um if you
are doing parallel staining where you
cocktail your your primaries together
they will be half uh they will be a
different species although if you're
doing sequential you can use the same
species and I highly suggest optimizing
a um
having an optimization strategy in which
you uh you do some stripping steps in
between the sequences so
um you can do uh some people do ER one
for uh 20 minutes at 95 degrees C some
you know it's it's really dependent on
the antibody so you'd have to do a
little bit of optimization uh with that
but yes you can use the same uh species
uh so the primary antibody was raised in
uh the same species yes you can
great we've got time for a few more
questions here so we'll go ahead and
continue this next question asks can
Bond RX be used to perform IHC plus RNA
scope or DNA scope stainings together
yeah excellent question
um absolutely yep um so we do have an
excellent partnership with ACD
um their application Specialists
um excuse me can help you with that
um it was a really fine-tuned uh just
about a year or two ago but we we've had
excellent uh staining with with ihd and
RNA scope and DNA scope so yes
great next question does dab have a
tendency to stain tissue edges in
addition to occluding and overstating
um
I'm me
um not necessarily
um so there are ways to optimize your
dab staining
um that could also be a
number of different histological issues
that may be going on that are uh prior
to going getting on the RX prior to
getting onto the pawn RX
um so that's sort of a complex question
I would have to ask a couple more
questions to to Really uh dive down
um
yeah to give you a better answer
um
we can follow up with that
perfect thank you next question here
where can I get this guide that you were
referring to today
yeah so great question so so the guide
really was in the presentation so we
were just trying to just show you how to
really set up Multiplex panels on the
Bon RX and also give you some some
optimization tips I think for further uh
down the road we'll give step-by-step
guides
um yeah maybe possibly
um you know please look for that in the
future
um you could also refer to the website
so we have an actual actual so our
website has um uh very very good
um
um pieces of information that that will
help you out absolutely so please please
um you know further down the road yes
and also our portal uh for content and
how-to guys is excellent so please refer
to the website
great
now earlier we had a question about
diluting the dab in the kit but this
next question asks can you dilute the
counter stains
oh yes absolutely so if you do have a uh
a counter stain in a kit for instance so
a refined dab kit you'll have your
hematoxyl encounter stain
um I would suggest putting it in an open
container and diluting it but if you
would like uh uh you can yes diluting
counter stains is is not a problem at
all yeah using using some di water
perfect
all right looks like we have time for
one more question here so we'll go ahead
and finish up with this one and this
last question asks what's the best
stripping protocol for a multiplex assay
ah yes it's a it's a very good question
so
um that is dependent on your uh primary
antibody
um and really The Binding uh that's
going on there
um so some people will use er1 for 20
minutes so that's a citrate buffer for
20 minutes at 95 degrees C some people
will use er2 for 20 minutes I mean like
I said it's really dependent on the
primary antibodies so you can
um try using controls and optimization
texting techniques so you know you'll
have maybe for instance if you have a
six Plex or actually I'll make it
simpler if you have a three Plex you can
take your first slide
um you can apply your first marker with
the Chrome gin
um do your stripping step and then apply
in the second sequence negate your your
second primary antibody
um and see if you have uh
yeah so so it's an optimization
technique that that that you'd have to
go through so I I it's a little complex
I can go I'm probably going to put
together another uh how-to guide down
the line
um and uh yeah well please look for that
in the future but um it's dependent on
the primary antibiotic the short answer
to your question
great
well we're going to go ahead and wrap up
there so I want to thank you again Mark
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Leica bio systems
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye